I Melinda Gates I'm co-chair at Villa
Linda Gates Foundation and what I'd like
to say that needin so many other girls
around the world is that many of us are
working on your behalf and that we
realize it takes a lot of things to
change society for girls but events laws
around education policy laws around
child protection laws about property
rights and changing programs to think
about how we reach girls because a lot
of times you're not reaching education
se servir I think if we change the
program so that we reach you in other
places out on your village you can lift
yourself up economically and make your
way to college and on to school and a
better life it's we applaud Anita and
all she has already done and those that
she also encourages in this struggle